oh my god you found a Garfield this is
actually probably one of the best
Garfield's I've seen him fine this is
going to be the interactive show I'm
gonna Instagram that [ __ ] yeah go on
Instagram and and you will find this
amazing Garfield just kind of something
at him but I really wish I did was give
you another another color to draw with
so we can see the definitely give me the
original during the original line and
the final oh shiz yeah that is a
Garfield ass Garfield till god you're
you're super sweet we interrupt this
podcast to Marie my new york today I
should have done it before and after so
i should take a stuff she brought to you
by Garfield's a body hidden insidious
Illuminati Garfield Garfield is watching
you poo stop stop looking for Illuminati
triangles and everything and start
looking for Illuminati Garfield's you
know what I want to do is combine
Garfield and guar yes warfield who are
filled well since Oderus and rhombus is
no longer with us sadly maybe there's an
opening well they just kicked that ball
vitrano they kicked off all the drama
why they had weird conflicts and I guess
she was like they had this whole big
spat over social media all over like a
Facebook account where they just
basically argued it out and they weren't
been having such a hard time yeah they
sort of also say admit that was like
this episode of branca Stubbs has
brought to you by hoping that war is
okay I really do I i I've never listened
to gwara but you know all the best of
them yeah um but like yeah they had this
whole spat where one of the guys
basically said like oh yeah we've really
enjoyed our time with Voltron but you
know we're not gonna use that character
for right now because all the characters
are like you they can kind of circulate
and they basically said like we're gonna
retire that character for the moment it
might come back who knows and then I
guess they didn't inform the woman who
who is vulva troughs and no big argument
over it oh that's bad that's bad for
that's a bad way to find out that you've
been canned yeah so I don't know the
like the full details but that was that
was you know some guar ass [ __ ] so uh
warfield whoa so a gwar field is uh I
will say using festival there are there
are complaints about the movies that
I've heard voice that i can understand
but I I you know personally hate them I
made me cry yeah so it made me cry
because crime is for butters I don't
like people or when I like it when
people are mean to the movie because you
know the movie has feelings and those
feelings must be protected at all costs
it's all aboot feelings yeah I will say
this was a lot more enjoyable to watch
them crying ISIL okay I've seen a I saw
a bunch of movies this year the one
whole bunch the worst i have to say the
worst movie animated otherwise that I
saw this year was home oh I'm amazing
heard which to me inside out is like the
polar opposite of home in terms of uh
what about the motional residents so
about when being bonded is wholly on a
breakdown oh yeah the fact that whenever
they have been emotional moment they did
they would literally turn the dial up on
the on the music oh god whose turn it
was bad I come to I mean this episode of
Frank guesthouse is brought to you by
home starring the bazinga man and
Rihanna Oh what she's in that too she's
really voice is the main girl mage
voices the main girl and then all the
music is Rihanna so it's not the girl
singing the songs but it's Rihanna and
uh okay I'm sorry to all the people who
work done on the movie I'm sure they did
a really heart that put a lot of hard
work into it over the course of four
years for I I that's not right one Obama
that's one of the worst animated movies
I've seen probably the left though
probably if I had to compare it to
anything that i saw that i hated the
last animated movie that I saw that I
really regretted watching of wishing i
had the time back was the Lorax really
yeah III epoke I'm gonna be very vocal
about what I don't like in this episode
I'm not saying that I hate the people
who worked on it because I don't they
obviously put in a hard work into this
movie but that movie was flawed as hell
oh the laurels both home and below I
like the Lorax was a perfect film first
and you want to
personally I've never seen it thank you
know what if it was we want to see a
perfect movie watch Rover danger film
yeah roving angel field is probably one
of the grinding personally that's the
way I'm going to just say a lot of
people if anybody listens to this who
actually knows who I am they will know
that I have an odd appreciation like
some people want to know the fetish so
some people want to know like how
they're not movies remain like I want to
know how they made Citizen Kane or
wizard of oz or snow white or that was
not a very narrow feet I don't know I
want to know everything about rover
Dangerfield like why was it made who was
on it what was the experience like it
was made because somebody made up the
name Rover Dangerfield yeah hey I got an
idea yes as a dog does that sound about
I get no respect but has a dome I'm
gonna get no respect for an hour and 15
minutes but I'm a [ __ ] dog get it get
it on the door kids love me and there
you know girls don't know over the house
aarani they will will flow they will
know hi I do guess a looking at the if
you do go through the art of inside-out
boat it's like a lot of the artwork it
has a very 70s quality to it does look
like the domos the malls kruky yeah Rob
Zombie almost directed this yeah it
looks I mean it looks goofy at times and
all mizuki it does look like these were
drawn by bit like the style of all these
sketches in all this concept art it does
look so much like Jim Henson's art yeah
like it almost end almost at the jim
henson meets dr. Seuss meets like um I
just even like how a child would draw
something even like it yeah we're like
oh god who was the guy he wasn't shel
silverstein his his artwork was a little
more like kind of [ __ ] than shel
Silverstein's Grigori no no I were bored
he was another like he was another one
that did like those kind of kids those
kids of those kids poem like fun goofy
silly poetry books like oh like I don't
know why dad is so thoroughly mad like
unless all I know you talking about yeah
he was like he was like the god he was
like the starch he was like the star
trek to shel silverstein Star Wars he
was like the other big pillar thing in
that
that wheelhouse of weight which of them
was more intelligent because you might
have to scourge oh yeah um I mean shel
silverstein also wrote the lyrics to a
boy named soon so it's like you know he
has probably a bigger track record he's
a bigger deal than this other guy whose
name escapes me that's got to tell you
something i can't remember this guy's
name Joe Stevenson one windows with
aromatic James do Stan James Stevenson
maybe that's in look as is I'm receiving
a note it's just in a memo is it from
tearing spoon shad prelutsky baby who is
this man we stopped the podcast this I'd
be like what is never got this episode
of those are so Frank guest house is
brought to you by who is this [ __ ]
guy well because the problem with having
modern technology is it like you're not
ever allowed to not know something I
don't know something it could be
remedied in seconds yeah well looky jack
prelutsky overlook his ass up if you
think this guy we're thinking of his
jack prelutsky please comment I was not
him all right he's got him I wasn't him
false alarm let us wrong woman damn you
jack prelutsky we dismantled the
patriarchy for you I mean we did it for
the sake of the Mad Max episode of house
I mean directly just messing to
patriarchy you would benefit everybody
this is true this episode is brought to
you by the dismantle having dismantled
the patriarchy I hope you guys are
enjoying it so far because we put a lot
of time and effort into dismantling the
patriarchy no the sign of pigs that's on
them I'm seeing an image or Jack caluski
it's not that [ __ ] guy this [ __ ]
yay but yeah there's this there's a very
ladies there's a very 70's look to to
the design sense behind inside out like
so yeah it's very Muppet eats free I'm
sorry dislike center spread up like an
early lineup it's like it feels like joy
they got her designed down pretty like
pretty solid from the get-go things I'd
like this version has a miniskirt yeah
yeah yeahs summer then it
we really do these like look like a
final mark I let me do another Garfield
okay Oh question does this joy look like
Erica very much yeah yeah okay okay does
it my god i thought i was going insane
so good is each of us look like um god I
feel like I look the most like discussed
I probably look like anger cross with
them fear does that make me fear and
sadness cure the glasses dude oh my god
this looks like this looks like fear
just now you are not here at satis all
but which of us is ping pong what's
happening wow that's nothing is the
catcher I probably look the most like in
this movie's Riley's dad voiced by the
impeccable Kyle MacLachlan Agent Dale
Cooper of twin peaks fame twin pigs dan
mayor of Portland exactly damn fine
father damn fine dicted I'm trying to
find guard over this way oh I'm not
saying us I'm not giving up guys I may
find us the Garfield Mike I may have
triumph run this [ __ ] no I'm not
even gonna prob I you up you have not
yet there's no Garfield no it has to be
a Garfield in it off by the Garfield
Garfield is like matter is what
everything is made of all things are
made of Garfield's how does Garnett
Garfield is love Garfield good play yes
what if I feel like shrek is like the
new Garfield it's like the weird kid she
like thing that everyone kind of fake
likes hey shrine yeah shrek is the new
Garfield yeah that's why I responsive
yeah yeah okay I do a rabbit Garf no I
mean that's good it is I imagine every
scribbly change his style I mean it's
like kids today are going to get thrown
into the world and they're going to be
kind of inducted with the habit of of
you're going to absorb that habit around
them of put on a smiling face put on a
happy face put a song in your step be
cheery like the people on TV we're
always happy but it's like it's a
it's I mean will we have yet to see what
will happen but I mean it's going to be
interesting to see like what comes from
this movie just putting the the message
out there of sadness is important and
you need it and you need to go through
it now just like whether through it but
it's like sadness is beneficial to your
life it's an important aspect of who you
are as a person yeah you need a healthy
range of emotions that are that are in
some kind of a bounce and then that's
also sort of a brain thing is like your
brain is kind of hard wired to assess
whatever situation you're in and try to
make you feel better first and foremost
like anything that's making you feel
that your brain wants to be like we're
gonna feel good again you know but
sometimes that's not viable and
sometimes you have to sort of allow
yourself to walk through the difficult
and a I mean it's like all the emotions
are too are there to like get you like
fear is to get you to run away from
something that might hurt you angers to
get you to defeat something that might
have hurt you oh yeah they say fear is
to make sure that this fan uh no anger
is there to make sure this fairness
really yeah because it's like if you
don't think it's fair game yeah and then
you will and discuss is there to keep
you from poison yourself socially and
literally and their fears to make sure
you're safe sadness is there no the
thing also about I thought I like this I
guess sadness joy is not the bad guy
like as much as you like joy just let
her do her thing yeah joy joy is the
protagonist than used to get my
education right but she starts at the
beginning who she's the first person
that she's the first emotion there and
she feels the most attachment to Riley
yeah because she sees all the things i
want to see that happy face yeah she
gets so happy so that sadness comes in
she wants to make sure that Riley look
more like because anytime she sees
discussed come up on the wheel or fear
or sadness or anger you see her just go
up because it wants to make sure that
she's happy whenever she sees a wall of
happy she's like good day everybody but
whatever this not that she gets
disappointed a good day is a day where
she does her job and no one else does
there oh my god yes you found the
Garfield
held on a happy day guys happy day happy
dia de lo my best Garfield oh but you
found it and that's what's important I'm
so happy using Nicolas Cage in the
national treasure movies like found the
national treasure names like not my best
national treasure now the last one
Nicolas Winding kid surrender of only
God finds the national treasure yeah
treasure protect her yeah but like I
mean that's a very human thing to want
it you know it's like anytime somebody
you care about or anybody's like you
know down or sad or upset you know it's
like it's the most human thing to want
to be like no no like be happy it's okay
like you know you want to cheer people
but sometimes it's not the best way to
go about things yeah drown everything
and happy Jews sadness sadness is there
to kind of enforce emotional bonds
sadness is there to kind of like get us
to take care of each other yeah and also
it's a beacon thing in the movie when
you see someone sad you want to go cheer
them up yeah so joy realize that she
wouldn't have got that many of the time
she would have gotten that happiness if
it wasn't for San this being that be
kind of showing that okay Riley is sad
let's go over right Riley is hurt and
she needs people to needs help yeah a
beacon for help yeah saying I need it's
the black box in an airplanes need Papes
yeah no I mean that's that's important
it's like out of out of the main
complaints that I can imagine people
having against movies one that Riley
isn't a super interesting character
which I I mean Riley isn't the character
Riley is the setting but also I think
Riley is one seriously yeah he's a blank
slate she's she's the Riley like Riley
has to kind of be a quote unquote
baseline normal girl so we can
understand so it's like we can see the
world as the rules of how these emotions
work with each other because if Riley
had too much specific quirks and stuff
going on then it would be like well
Riley's just weird like that that's not
how but the chupah to choose any wieder
it would bring attention away from
really crazy stuff that's going on on
her head yeah the world that she's in
even the back
she's living in a house that's weird
it's a normal school there's nothing
really special about it or that she's an
eleven-year-old girl and her parents let
her walk to school alone through San
Francisco in a big talent yeah in a new
town that you've never been to but I
mean I get it I understand like this
guy's probably in San Francisco because
he's like working in some new text art
arms probably some weird like place dash
guy he's some weird like new agey
hands-off parent but no but the other
thing is like you know she's in a
situation where you know she's going
through a lot of time where you're still
you're getting that age where you're
figuring out what your emotions are yeah
they do and and you know the different
you know enjoy the spengler hiding of it
just the fact that she's going through a
change she's growing up you know and the
fact that she goes through a major
change outside we just are moving from
somewhere that she's the most
comfortable I mean you look at look at
this look she's got those five areas
she's got honestly honestly like of
island and friendship Island family I
mean family in honesty hockey is the
most important but I mean all those
things are changing like hockey she
can't play hockey anymore not the way
you used to not the way she moves her
friends with our whole hockey team just
the things that made her happy in
Minnesota where she was from and now
it's all on and it's a it's a complete
you know your whole [ __ ] world is
flipped upside down yeah I never move I
remember moving and feeling like oh my
god I'm not gonna make any friends I'm
it's awkward I don't feel right here
this isn't long it's like really not
necessarily be the most interesting
character ever but it's like the whole
movie is about her be like the things
that will make her an interesting human
being and it's interesting to to peer
inside of someone's mind at that stage
during a situation yeah it's like that's
checking in with Riley's almost like
just a bonus to show the consequence
will she think yeah also yeah it's in
this case she is the shoes yes you
anyways it is kind of like what creates
the obligatory sort of like ticking
clock and the last act it's like when
you know it's like to we have to see
Riley starting to get in increasing
trouble and put herself at further risk
to understand the stakes of which you
know the crumbling
her brain is impacting the real world
really like the ones that moving the
Fantastic Voyage or was it the one where
they go fantastic mr. Bullock the one
where they go inside they shrink down
into Santa's highway I was gonna say
it's very much like that in the sense
but the thing is they're not aware there
there there in the subconscious they
don't leave and I let into some moments
in the movie where you're like oh that's
so great that they can't feel that
something like that the abstract thought
stuff and honestly yes like we said
before it's all subjective my
subconscious is kind of like guarded
place that it's not like i was moses
jones when which would have been an
interesting movie if there wasn't as
much cracking live action the thing
about i was moses jones is like i don't
think it ever got into the psychological
osmosis jones was only about physiology
and don't worry big gross yeah science
its is it that was gross papatoetoe cash
bandage around ginger you [ __ ] Thrax
your boss vs jones i just want to see
how's mostest in indiana finally team
but the brothers oh that's right the
Joneses yeah enjoy that mr. are then mr.
gesture jones from the county fro song
and mrs. Jones from the me and mrs.
Jones mrs. Joe mrs. Jones yes I want all
these Joneses oh and um keeping the joke
the Joneses from the David Duchovny
movie keeping up with the Joneses
anybody see that no it's about a fake
family that was created by marketing
firms you like go infiltrate a is a fake
family David two companies the dad it's
a fake family created by an advertising
firm that's hard to just go into a
suburban neighborhood and just like show
off products and like Africa normal
family and to show off conspicuous
consumption to everyone in the
neighborhood it's very truman show us i
know right it but it does not sound that
far off talk now he's drawing really
awful Garfield's please continue there's
no that's a great car field I don't know
when I was kind of aunty I wish I saw
her key wide
hey he's one of your melting you want
out of a Garfield well I mean a little
nod to italian cuisine organized I mean
turkey leg massage is where that was in
a tighter Fiji ok I guess in time to
it's a trickling turgor leave ah there's
no and it's also i wonder what inside
out is going to do to parents so I
parents are going to see the kids
they're gonna take their kids to see
parents up parents are gonna take the
kids to this and a good thing yeah you
know I really shouldn't just like demand
my kid to be happy all the time like in
or freak out if my kid isn't happy all
the time if my kids sat i'm going to
validate them being sad and be like okay
what's wrong yeah find out about your
kid and come a question you know leave a
comment if you're gonna be a better
parent leave a comment and your kids in
the kid box go to your kids youtube
channel and leave comments asking if
they're okay Frank your kid on facebook
and comments on everything they post
yeah that's not creepy yeah not adults
not smothering yeah you know go to your
kids Facebook page and post memes that
made you think of them today yeah i
really i really like movies like this
cuz is they're not the same this movie
is much more not good nature is the
wrong word but it's warmer than the
paranorman but I kind of put them
together because paranorman has a
similar like oh there's that's not your
typical like be yourself and you know
you you know that movies about like fear
and what it does to people and learning
to see beyond the shitty things people
do because everyone's kind of also the
faster like but I mean like even a
paranormal parents don't really wear
soon his dad his dad is a Martian I've
never seen that boo camping like he says
that one thing that's like so not an ass
to see I need a good way that's it oh
yeah oh yeah dad is an [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah oh my god but then it's good girls
it's Norman you know Jeff Garlin knows
just how proud I am of him he really
crowning achievement Jack well i'm the
project girl just in general as is usual
big nough you do upward he played the
SAS pink unicorn
a movie oh yeah it's a toy story three
reeds yeah like a thang your level small
pool to drop drop what best pink
district you I mean they're more out
there than you think I guess yeah but
it's not like I best paper the part of
the book it goes to jump wrong with
garlic [ __ ] ya bein ya know like I just
like it was nice to see another on those
movies where it's like oh it's you know
it's a more sophisticated some more
elegant message than you know not that
not that being yourself is bad news
messages like that even a lot of kids
movies that like send the message of be
other people absorb the identities of
those around like even monsters
University I thought they had a really
good message Lizzie I haven't seen a lot
of the reason I haven't seen like I said
brave monsters University cursor like it
cars 2 is a great movie to watch if you
really really really just want to like
watch something just ask questions we're
just like they won't be answered why
like that's it like that's that's if you
have John Lassiter's home phone number
watch carves to and call him every time
you have a question by a friend of mine
I did just live tweeted yesterday i love
i love this movie just how bad it is he
lot because he never saw it he says I'm
gonna watch this movie because everyone
told me that it's worth watching and I'm
gonna do it b-movie the Jerry Seinfeld
see movies your favorite Oh Aaron OB
movie we watched that one night I really
wanted to watch B movie just so I knew
what it was and I was like holiday and
the biggest regret of his life was watch
I don't know in retrospect I regret I
regret eating white cast on more than I
regret watching beam I am at my castle
you didn't make me my white castle at a
White Castle oh yeah it was a white
castle in vegas there's white castle in
vegas yeah it's all the only one like
west of the Mississippi yeah all right
we'll [ __ ] y'all cause like you like my
castle well you know I gross body
castles grew up with like that
how did you grow up with white guys
hunting and how did you know Castle you
as my folks are from from back east and
I would go out there frequently so like
skyline chili white castle larosa's
painted like oh oh there remember [ __ ]
like people don't remember [ __ ] like
punches I try think what I've got in the
way in the way of fast food I grew up
with when I was when I grew up with
chiefly subway and uh chubbies out of
any ugly I November chubby cheek chubby
chubby he was like you chubbies was like
I don't even know if it wasn't change or
if it was just in the one small town i
was in as a kid but basically chubbies
was like a mini version of mel's diner
where you could have like bees yeah i'm
not a creeper it was called chubbies and
it was like it was like very 50 style
and like everything was like various
fifties nostalgia and I had a burger
served to me and like a like a cardboard
Ford edzel and it was really cool like
the kids meal just was served to you in
a cardboard ford edsel I just can't get
over the fact that the place was getting
chubby I don't write well this was the
90s before the kids obesity epidemic was
something can't talk shop chubby is like
chubby of chubby Spain who is the
establishing creator of chubbies has
sleep apnea during his waking life huh
Oh baby Jeffy yeah there is oh my god I
need to photograph all of these all
these amazing Garfield's terrible I'm
going to say this um I will just talk
like that for us next time cook a
telemarketer calls you answer like that
you know hey Andy named Joey helm
identical movie just ended just just
gross and weird out a telemarketer until
you just we use of his own accord and a
[ __ ] covered in th e cheeto cashed
there's another establishment Midwest
that heza has a name that's always it's
always dazzled me and that's tutors
biscuit world
tutors biscuit world is some real [ __ ]
dude let's give all this language go out
as real as too much missed you tomorrow
sounds exactly like a thing that would
not be real Reuters biscuit world is
what you would name a fake thing why
would you have a whole world dedicated a
business how much you want my name
tutors exist have a biscuit sketch in
the world here's here's who I just guru
is not a real man and he does not have a
world of biscuit I started googling
tutors biscuit world at tutors biscuit
wasn't even the first result tutors
biscuit world ours was the first
anticipate a result so you know that you
see this limit let me see he sounds like
there's so many toch about it oh there's
so many to miss your worlds they're all
over was your agenda biscuit Way galaxy
sounds like sling blade but here's you
oh my god it's squishy for the record
Jim hate you [ __ ] cute for the record
tutors is felt like the family out like
to yeah like the tutors not like tutors
oh what a tutor yes not like farting as
the biscuit man that's what was the you
Toby tutors I think I only pop I'll a
boat flinging miss you tell me tutors
i'm imagining scooter from Captain EO
but with a tea instead of an age you
know I dig to rate the map oh stop it's
not I mean anything well all the
biscuits anyone who look you guys have
seen captain EO yeah I've seen captain
EO or distant not bad me okay you seen
captain EO I beliefs in canal with oh
you guys are captain EO captain EO is so
I oh yeah it's the please show anyway
yes captain EO this is my favorite
Garfield every which one the the Money
dout one this one the [ __ ] up Garfield
did the scribbly 10 the first 1i then
yeah hey second hey you guys want to
know what you guys want to know what
what famous philosopher inside out like
would really you know a famous
philosopher would real
love inside out green des portes no they
just made it up you sing when I dick
hard but you wanna guess huh uh uh okay
okay I'm glad your [ __ ] minds it's
neat trick Oh Nietzsche get that need
each is on the record for saying the
exact [ __ ] that is like knit inches on
the record saying you really enjoyed
this meadow I'm gonna I'm gonna blow
your mind I'm gonna make you lose your
[ __ ] i'm going to mine ok this is
Nietzsche from the gay science all right
don't laugh about the title of his book
ok ok so this is a Nietzsche word for
word how little you know the happiness
of man you comfortable and good-natured
ones for happiness and misfortune our
brother and sister and twins who grow
tall together or as with you remain
small together ha do it to gauge sign
gay science do it to gauge oh there's a
gay sign those funds yes science but I
could think of a gay time to be slippery
when wet we all walked right into a
story when wet good uh yeah k the
slippery because they swim all the time
that's terrible this I regret saying
that gays are actually aquatic people
they have gills Kevin Costner in
Waterworld he was gay in pink kills yeah
yeah ghosts are used to going under who
are you doing right now remind me their
name I'll fault like very Paul Lynde ish
yeah we wanna let its heads crunchy I'm
still away mana nija the gay science
because the basically the science of
happiness um okay yes I am she I should
you not inside out as a Nietzsche ass
movie change with nature will explain
your thesis I just waited like
Nietzsche's just said he's word for word
I saying happiness and sadness are
siblings who grow together that's the
whole point of the movie a lot
leadership is I thought happiness is a
warm puppy happiness is a warm Beatles
records happiness is a warm bun
biscuit world yeah this is a biz awards
get world nothing should happen if
tutors just your world with sponsored
eyes I would lose my [ __ ] I'm where
badging visible Disney work I want
tutors biscuit want to do some cross
promotion with the show the tutors loyal
combos decadent like like backstabbing
political machinations and crazy like
medieval sex when you think of your
world of biscuits medieval to that was
like a costly dick knows this mistake
that haunted ever deezer Scrooge good
you wanted Yogi Bear oh those tamales
dish you're always a great speaking of
ghostly things go sleep in spookiness
and terror oh [ __ ] wait are you is this
what I think it is one yeah we got get
to get the copy on I'm being handed a
bulletin ding dong ding ding ding on
Avatar per company handed a bulletin
here in the studio says it says they
were shipped out of order um there's
yeah these are never in order they go by
the go things by the the number that's
written on the back side sorry it's okay
yeah well no here's I was queuing up I
counted up to track I was real excited
because I was go there was no lead time
on the tape that they sent him Oh more
Garfield's the Garfield's are
multiplying dude they're they're they're
multiplying like rabbits uh-oh she okay
I'll ready we are ready okay this
episode of tanked SS is actually in real
lion real time yeah yeah I'll like all
those other fake sponsorships of things
that don't exist like Frank s tubs we're
gonna we're gonna lose elephant land and
reuse you we're gonna lose the real
sponsorships bike by putting all these
other confusing fake ones yeah it's like
I don't know this is like tours biscuit
world I don't want to get thrown into
the mix with all these fake things named
Manny no tutors is Degas real [ __ ] is
brought to you by by tear
wien spooky days that's right darling
spooky days open every days except
thursdays to sundays oh this year's
tournament spooky days promises to bring
much frightening and very horror very
horny i don't worry lead um now
featuring a bathroom oh yeah they guys
like a picture a little portal let here
yeah um the bathroom is open thursdays
through sundays yeah the bathroom is
open it says every day's including
thursdays through sunday so you can go
to tournaments boogie days when the
haunt is closed like that room is open
sri alee kind of them i mean like a
bathroom is sort of a basic human right
I mean who know maybe like the maybe
like Terrence movie days is like locate
off a major interstate to you know it's
like it's a it's a rest stop that people
may need to use when they're getting
somewhere else not necessarily to go to
the home ms that's a service like Thank
You Terry wherever you are thanks for
providing septic services and they got a
they got a photo here of the actual be I
guess the big week overturning spooky
days his name is uh you'll heal your or
your um I'm gonna say with jor cuz their
day orh your your hair boom hae why is
the be small and the rest of the word is
big it's like the lesson the last name
is capitalized except for that beat hae
r BM jorc terrible hair bum who is the
executor of creations or 10 release 50
days this is like a really official
operation I would like to visit them
yeah they just never say when I'm in Des
Moines man you just don't say where they
are maybe it's like maybe it's like some
of those more more exclusive and maybe
you got to get off my comments mailing
list it may be you have to like get a
ticket then they'll tell you the
location later just say a website
there's no way to contact them and they
sent they just send these promo it is
yeah um whatever here boom welcoming all
terrowin's quickie days fanatical 'he's
to this year's hunt HL 0 NT that's soon
very wrong um maybe it's like an owl
hoots maybe there's now we'll see
there's a quote from mr. hare boom oh
yeah I'm am dream of a place where one
day's children the word is children I
think about one children children our
children children can spooky can spooky
hey I mean it's this result worthwhile a
drink I'm taking that to me that it's
kid-friendly tearing spooky days yeah so
you know it seems like they seem
relatively good nature yeah so bring you
kiss determine Scooby days it's not like
one of these more these more extreme
mainstream all set you know they they
don't say they're not for kids but
they're going to say oh yeah we
recommend no one under 13 but you can
still your kid is still allowed in yeah
that's the gate and that legacy in hot
water you know yeah like they're going
to make an effort to be friendly to
children that's I in respect that's nice
you know I mean oh it's nice to round
out I think there should be more more
family-friendly go ahead out there ah
anyone listening go ahead and let us
know if you know what terylene spooky
days is and where it is and maybe we'll
do an episode on our experienced
attorneys kooky days yeah well i am i
hoping that maybe like is Halloween
draws near they will send us maybe some
free tix yeah get it like tapas alright
text I mean we've been me this just bugs
yeah yeah yeah I would love a tick
infestations of design of that maronite
anniversary of tix don't know no I want
my blood to be drained by something like
totally unglamorous I don't want like
some fancy pants Dracula I'm a
working-class boy I just want my blood
sucked by two things doctors and bugs I
want them to just send us an entire
season as a pic remember Lou tired what
were ya potential Warburg of Patrick
Warburton thing yeah I want to combine
tim burton and Patrick floor burn that
is my favorite oh that's a good Garfield
that's a good field one of my top ten
fields take up the whole the whole thing
oh I like this kind Gary Larson you can
throw field this my [ __ ]
these are some great Garfield's this was
some really great government this
episode's really brought to you by
garfield yeah he's you know he's hating
on Monday he's loving on the son you
never a big fan if you are interesting
thing if you guys have a collection of
Garfield merch and you're confused as to
how to sell it um consult the video on
YouTube there's a video on youtube on
how to sell your Garfield collection the
entitled how to study Garfield
collection and I I highly Ryan and go to
the Garfield con on Long Island yeah I
highly recommend everyone watch the how
to sell your Garfield collection video
because it's [ __ ] wild Garf it's a
wild ride to watch the how to sell your
Garfield collection it reminds me a bit
of this guy who I think is from Norway
who did these videos of him showing off
his collection of VCRs was uh he
collected VCRs and he didn't have a huge
great grasp of English hell is Norwegian
guys showing all of his VCRs and he
keeps on trying to in broken English be
like Panasonic good good electronics or
magnavox a very good electronics in that
one and then we get to ones like no no
bad electronics of that one this and so
he did not a huge grasp of English but I
knew that like most of the inner most of
YouTube is going to be english-speaking
so it's like bad than the drums yeah bad
the lictor well cuz YouTube like from
America yep whoa is there is there a
raving your potty just get back from EDC
bruh let's get back from your EDC the
odds but my EDC tickets for next year
we'd get my EDC tickets well excuse me
we're having some EDM in my pocket no
wonder i was going to vegas so recently
you were on that EDC [ __ ] it where is
EDC in Vegas they moved it out I LA cuz
people died people died at EDC it has
why because they like couldn't control
their [ __ ] they like notch fences now
and somebody died like why would anybody
like willingly diet EDC it's such a dumb
thing to do I don't think anybody stood
up and was like fruit oh I'm getting a
bulletin eric is gesturing consuming
lots of pills oh not enough water
this is thing I don't think anybody
overdose I think somebody was a crushed
under people like what yeah like they
the security wasn't letting people in
yet and there were like these chain link
fences up and they like pulled them down
and crushed somebody hears thing if
anyone's gonna die shouldn't be died for
like a cause like Manny kind in forest
even just even like better music and
like electronic dance music is not like
I mean I I don't know I just can't
imagine like anybody like just like
saying oh I I need to i'm going to just
listen to electronic dance music for the
sake of listening to electronic dance
music wait people listen to electronic
dance music just to dance yeah i mean i
don't know there's certain songs that I
some of the ones they're more structured
see the thing is like if you're at a
place on BBC or imagining like totally
atonal a melodic electronic dance music
there are hints of melodies but I think
the point is like you have the driving
beat and then there are variations on
top of that because the point at least
in the live setting is to move I want to
see like Ed jazz were just like a bunch
of guys with their laptops all hooked up
to one mixing board and like there's one
guy handling the rhythm and everyone
else is just doing like a different
synthesized like solo improv over it I
believe there is an active those you go
oh and they're actually pretty
impressive like they actually made a
cool I saw a video that was like that it
was like a instead of one DJ was a bunch
of different guys kind of building a
song together up there you know and
that's when I gets more artistic ok i
would i would be down to check that up
everyone knows that this edj this
electronic dance jazz band um keep it to
yourself you can net a better place for
no one take that secret to your grave
can you find a better place for pork and
champagne keep to yourself yeah Oh big I
am repeater he was just document off the
press I'm documenting the [ __ ] out of
all this Garfield so did so we've just
serves another thing about inside out
that was like a that was like a
criticism I her I like saw some people
kind of latch on and that's the idea
like firm
that's all about needing to embrace
Addison the point of the movie being how
important sadness is sadness is not
really enough of a character doesn't
give enough she doesn't get enough
screen time the biggest complaint i've
heard about the movies that ok so anger
is anger sadness is sadness why does joy
so multifaceted why is you get widest
joy it said why is joy get angry
frustrated and sarcastic well it's
supposed to be just sadness does kind of
it well never at fur is prolonged time
is joy does but like even satis be like
oh yeah I really like that memory yeah
it's when the sad thing but in the end
for joy is prolonged contempt there's
annoyances there's all stuff like she's
blaming anger even gets happy and giddy
at the chance to express anger yeah like
fear lies his purpose yeah but like fear
like gets annoyed when he's watching a
dream and he gets really excited about
coming up with the major list of all the
things that could go wrong like takes a
leisure in being he takes pleasure a
different emotion in doing his job like
discussed is really the only emotion
that is actually one note Joyce is
multi-faceted cuz she gets the most air
time and does the most and learns the
most of that would be she's the one that
has to has two grown two just scorned
ensures enjoys also challenged by a cab
Alya yeah you know her basic squat yeah
and the thing is it's like the point of
the movies like sometimes you know joy
you want to be master and commander
Russell Crowe of Riley's brain buddy you
know occasionally Riley's going to get
so sad that even you are sad yeah you
know occasionally you need public oh
sure speaking of sad things with joy
whoever animated that scene worked with
Joy's in the da Vinci and she sees it
just holding all the warmth and looking
at it whoever animated that seems in a
lawsuit oh yeah yeah give them a [ __ ]
medal yes there's job there's such
really great a motive yeah like animated
actor yeah like we are just act yeah
what why is this acting what I wanna say
is like this
is this is acting that the animator is
doing this is not something that's
specifically coming from google it is
like warranties for putting into or yeah
course a lot of it's coming from the VA
but the part of that then you're
referencing is the part that the
animators pulls any poll or two she
should kill she hates that suit oh yeah
and they were I'm not knocking Amy
Poehler at all but one thing is like
synthesis outside of outside it's sad to
say but outside of the industry of
animation the culture of big animation
has a lot of times like people watch an
animated movie and they don't know that
a lot of what they're responding to to
emotionally is not what they're hearing
from the voice actor it's what the
animators did to convey that emotion in
the above the movements of the character
yeah it's what with what they see on
screen but people forget that we're the
music by by describing some marks on oh
yeah and that's just like I mean it's
like like we said earlier joy it's the
[ __ ] kicked out of her in this movie
towards towards the latter half and it's
like she trembles yeah that's but that's
the job yeah when we run basye oh Jesus
but she isn't she's in a fetal position
quivering like unable to move what I
feel like you know being in the pit of
of forgotten memories would probably
[ __ ] up any of like any emotion i guess
a it's like pictures getting really good
at handling implicit death in their
movies i feel like there should be more
of that dead or what characters in my
phone back yeah mortality yeah we want
we want more pics or fix our embrace
your mortality more death more def more
def def i started doing like my own
version of of memento mori where
whenever i finish a tweet under 140
characters i make up the character gap
with skull emojis yeah it's hard for me
to but the sad thing is i don't think
it's actually giving me that clarity in
that context of remembering my own
mortality because I just like looking at
the skull know something like yeah these
are rent these are so cool imma go on my
geo city's website rippy blood five
yeah did the rotating chief of have
someone flipping you off yeah that's now
a geocities angelfire tripod that never
would load any website for me when I
want everyone lockjaw Oh live drum zanga
zanga zanga zanga zanga zanga was my
favorite party chamber singers in saying
the same de dum dum flea is a voice in
this movie flea from the red hot chili
pepper noisy Oh farm berries oh yeah
Donny from the wild thornberrys or if
the Indians should be trusted you know
Nikki azaleas ya know I just I just
totally forgot about that those
Thornberrys quite wild if anybody can
find this mean for me that somebody uh
suave I on this means somebody swapped
out the most interesting man the world's
head with Nigel Thornberry and it's just
the way it's written is so funny and
I've never been able to finding I'm
always all it's like I don't always
hahaha but when I when I do it's mesh oh
and it's perfect there is still the
batch of blueberry bath curtain it just
a splashing Oh make it stop laughing oh
yeah Paula Poundstone and Bobby Moynihan
who's Bobby wanted him there he's the
other forget her oh that's right and
Pete docter the director place male Oh
her flea is one of the cops in the pink
cloud town that and have the Chinatown
pun he leaves the one that gets called
Jake well yeah yeah Lee is the recipient
mine worker god playing what are you
doing today well you can use you as a
boy so Louie yeah passing through easier
rashida Jones is the Cougar Ori Allon
loriana yeah mother said yeah now
they're telling people they're held
tapes oh hell peeps I just like the I
did like being the and I thought
something that was really great because
it's like they they kind of glossed over
who that that party clown was i tells
like you see the party clown and see
what memory he comes from and then you
see his emotions inside the party clown
themed
and I just I love that joke because it
was like it was an obvious one but it
was like well crafted and probably could
have hardened its delivery of like that
the party clowns emotion just being like
six years of drama school for this
retrying who did p doc your voice six
years ago so that cloud is anger that
clown has a channel degree it was look
some of the line readings like sir we're
reading a large amount of sass and they
animate just this giant like pivoting
like vice of the head going sass yeah
and even that and what was it like
there's one thing that people have noted
said like when we zoom into the mom's
brain like sadness seems to be in the
pilot seat in flight kind of like
commanding the other emotions and when
we zoom to the dad spring anger seems to
be in command yeah but what's
interesting is like when we zoom into
those two brains the mom at the data all
the other emotions are way more cohesive
and cooperative than they are in Riley's
brain for a lot older measure yeah it's
almost like so that you can kind of say
oh this movie isn't same time moms are
sad and dads or angry with this movie is
saying like this model was probably once
a sad kid and his dad was probably once
a mad kid but it's like now that they're
older your emotions are more cooperative
and coalesced yeah and I mean it's as
you get older you know you're here you
learn more complex finances I like the
theme and what I think is great about
this movie is like it hints at a sequel
but it's a sequel that you know picture
would never make because there's a big
puberty button on the upgraded console
and you know Pixar's not going to make
the puberty goofy well yeah it's like
it's like yeah you know what would come
but we don't need to see it like it's
better just as a fun you know a little
little bit early the sequel to
ratatouille you don't need a sequel to
most of these you know something simple
but they're not making some food like
toy story has managed to get out I liked
its its sequels but it I don't know how
they're gonna do a toy story 4 and have
it be like I didn't think they could do
to I didn't think they could do three
they did and now it's like you've
achieved something grand
to a degree you know nailing toy story 3
and all that heavy [ __ ] at the end and
then the whole moving up like what would
you possibly her toys story Florida this
car feels like he's made out of some
kind of acid l think there's a melting
Garfield oh oh he's very melted he's
like this is my lovely two-thirds melted
this is terrible melt field these are
some great Garfield's we should we get
avatari on the yellow of your losses you
anyhow it's we've crested the to our our
11 you learn more you have an exposing
remarks um go see this movie it's a go
see this movie if she tells me i would
say if you want to you know go in and
then leave the theater feeling very
satisfied and I'm assuming like if you
if some people step around for a spoiler
fill pockets they've already seen yeah
but if you haven't and you who don't
mind everything having been spoiled for
you already go ahead suit again yeah if
you don't always see it again i might
say it again like to see it I kind of
feel like I want to give Matt maxence to
and actually see that again to ya double
food while still in theaters oh yeah
cylinders it's been a flutist forever no
he's sub double feature when we saw it
inside out we passed by Mad Max being
played unlocked through a Mad Max
screening to get to the inside out if
everyone yelled at me [ __ ] set out yeah
I'm not sitting down sir I have to go to
the other theater cuz this is not my
movies a poorly designed movie house
where you just have to walk through
every role theaters every Plex is just
kind of stacked against usually that one
[ __ ] like the tubing product aren't
to excuse me I'm sorry party they
doesn't even use any quiet about it
excuse me excuse me I need to get to my
film did you move your knees sorry I
need to get my fill I have to go over
these many many me your tickets to a
film sir why the hell did you man
back to the movie man really on your
purses strap is wrapped around my ankle
I need you to remove it I need to get to
fill I need to a film you see the spills
film film where is my film where my
pants that's it it's like it's good to
see like Pixar is you know Pixar has a
nailed formula it's good to see them you
know play with that in break new ground
because i keep getting i want say
they're getting not necessarily like
staunch competition but they're getting
like Mara tible competition from guys
like the lego movie from other animated
studios but I'm so looking forward to uh
I'm so looking forward to seeing more
movies coming out like the peanuts
movies have a tidy book the trailer for
the peanuts movie looked interesting
yeah i heard the idea and i was like oh
and i saw the trailer and I was like oh
so my questions could be very dear I
like the way they're approaching the
animation it seems tickets yeah that's
it's there keep treating it very um it's
gonna be like originally the treating of
my clothes word is oh so it's gonna be
like episodic I I might have been yet I
don't know if it's gonna be quite that
Oh see Charlie Brown was another one
that at least it's not all the specials
but but some of the ones I grew up with
were you know her resin yet you know
there's like it charlie try browse kind
of a depressed guy so it's like the
woman they go to the spelling bee and
everyone's a dick like oh yeah hurts
like it hurts your soul a little bit so
like I hope they maintain time to make
it like dour heavy but I hope they
maintain that's you know resonance know
when I Charlie Brown's not necessarily
fluffy you know like what would Charles
Schultz apparently said about Charlie
Brown sleep the penis is like the great
American unsuccess story yeah pain its
yeah pain yeah he and he always hated
that name peanuts peanuts I said well we
call ish there's a strip Peanuts is it
what Wow because you know like parents
call the kids peanut is like I don't
know pero those already done of that
because he wanted to call it good old
Charlie Brown
grew up with conscious call Mike Sparkie
and so many yellow yeah okay like named
after people like good old something why
do you dad would stand there is like no
like no we're naming a peanuts are not
getting trustworthy Frank s total for
the rest of his life you would just say
oh I do a strip with trout sleeping that
all right I do this new [ __ ] I do the
charlie brown one I do that that Snoopy
bullshit's thing come on us 10 free [ __ ]
I'll i do the funny paper [ __ ] with
the stupid dogs he'll be gained a bit
Charlie Brown and that in that boy will
play the piano Chuck being a blanket kid
yes I bet that's what that's exactly
Carlisle told it yeah Chuckie beard the
blanket boys kinky Kelly in a sexy story
speaking of sexy studs Charlie Brown
Charlie Brown he's got a head like wow
oh yeah and I got like a one nebulous
hair spray yeah that looks like a peanut
yeah especially especially in the in the
in the new movie the fact that it just
looks like a cute just to please pubic
hair tonight for him that's like the
biggest complaint about the size like it
looks really cool tip of the fact that
there's a giant pubic hair coming out
charlie brown stain I mean people were
talking about Charlie's head looking
like Charlotte Charley Loeb of a scrotum
with some with a lone pubic hair on it
for a time dry fuels everything is awful
everything is disgusting living living a
dream okay this it's prepubescent ball
in this Charlie but that's another thing
I use now we'd be my friends we used to
movie including working when I used to
work on Bojack horseman it all sit in a
big pool Michael also storyboard on
Bojack horseman spin soon to commence
its second season season six all right
season two same thing what numbers
whatever footing yeah continue oh but we
sit a big room to go and then we talked
it was one day where we sat around in
your life but just come up with really
bad peanuts satellite that's our word
Charlie Oh
or girl no it's um you know what was
another one that we came up there's some
bad ones um it's malignant Charlie Brown
oh I favorite is so that's our work
Charlie Brown yeah it's still a key
that's what I get happens like I want to
go wow Charlie Brown got himself into
that situation missing body and don't
look outside being a dick don't look
outside Charlie Brown no um jet fuel
can't melt steel beams Charlie Brown
count the tiles Charlie Pratt like
really just horrible Oh keep away from
the bike shop Wow same card to your a
hot shower Charlie Brown no no I got ya
better that that's the end of my
children that's there's no more charlie
brown after that charlie brown bird down
ten years ago it's the end children now
we gotta know whatever these snails and
our colorful collection oh god I can I
don't need like this we call me I don't
remember the I know there was like there
were like Garfield collections that were
like like Garfield Strip collection
books that were like making fun of his
weight like Charlie Brown no darling oh
they're a gargoyle the thing that bugged
me was at Garfield it was just like I
would see posters and Sloan said like
knowledge is brain food and like things
like exercise every day was I'm dying of
a [ __ ] about knowledge Rick Gladia would
be like the opposite you'd be like no
people easy and get diabetes and die
because that's that's where I it's
that's that's the gargling eat as much
starch as possible and be antisocial at
all huh yeah sure just sit down and kick
a dog and just eat pasta I was marinara
mugabe almost most gender like just like
Tweety Bird is just the most gender
gender confused cat I will tell you who
is the most gender confused character on
in cartoons and it is not is not any of
these like at least like gender
ambiguous characters his [ __ ] bugs
bunny I was saying this i was saying
this on the drive back from vegas and
then this was said like by a crack some
video and i had no idea that like there
was this weird synergy of mind power but
Bugs Bunny is like the most like
gender-fluid character ever to be put on
TV yeah like how many times did both
money like the war to someone trying to
kill him by just like flirting and
letting himself get filled up wall and
drag many legs dark I mean like winning
Bugs Bunny is the Joker about now gender
identity he beats everybody by simply
like being out gender and our kissed
introduced a little chaos upset these
down this elaborate dresses yeah and
everyone becomes morning yeah well
that's I mean that's video which a
sequel the inside i will be for well
because they would have to introduce
like the horny emotion yeah it's not
let's not do that although i mean there
would be really funny like this you'd
have like a songs i'm waiting for the
cops suit now i'm waiting for someone to
do like a comic on top but i did you
where it's like you know Riley is like
16 years old she's at a party oh and
she's just somehow it gets into a room
with a guy and just saying all these
does he on its anger its sadness
innocence innocence joy so that ends
it's like gossamer monster called for me
just burst into headquarters rule brick
wall like the kool-aid man [ __ ]
everything up I'm Linda didn't introduce
Ronnie would be the Tasmanian devil yeah
damn basically think that's that's all I
reacted that's all I've seen apparently
they're actually on a researcher side
apparently the research they can sort
the consultant for you know planning
inside out one of the six Cardinal quote
unquote emotions that they the
researchers found didn't get used in the
movie in that surprise only surprise is
like separate from well there was fear
and surprise but they realized that
surprise this part is is kind of in the
same thing as fear yeah it's like how
does surprise this isn't happy here or
like yeah surprise would be like so
redundant next to fear right this is a
happier version are they really are more
like reaver they didn't know if it was
like okay because people some people say
that on you know that there's only you
know five core emotions just like in the
movies something to say this like the 20
yeah but it's called for the key because
unless you want to do is it's a lot of
what they call pencil biology to know
it's not it's all digital now is called
do you really want to have to animate
search of seven characters on screen
throughout the entire movie yes the
north entrance is better because in cg
usually you're in charge of a shock
character yeah so you're pretty much
animating all the characters in a shot
for every shot so just like you have to
just pose all the puppets pretty much
yeah it's pretty much yes exactly what
you're doing that's interesting that in
cg it's not like with traditional
animation because like you go to I mean
look at the way like the work clothes
for a traditionally 2d animated movie
it's like each character has its own
designer and animator animation team
yeah I mean like in a traditional
animated film because usually have a
supervisor people to work under them and
a 2d film but in the CG films it's all
the choreography is all planned and
everything usually for a fluffa shots
it's given to one enemy what one that's
going to CEO Ron as interesting as I'm
wondering it that way I know is that
like at the expensive kind of like that
individual artistic expression doesn't
means like I've hung out with you enough
to like see you talk about how this guy
animated like you know to talk about oh
yeah phila TVs from Hercules such an
eric goldberg character yeah the thing
is you can determine if you really look
closely
determine who added what shot by how
they draw eyes how they certain matter
is it but like in CG when someone is
only in charge of the same I it's hard
surgery in a movie like cars where
they're all freaking cars they all are
the same yeah there are certain things
if you're an animator if you watch the
mana made you could if you really conclu
into some people you can say like oh
that's a sound so scene but in CGS that
you're all working with the same puppet
it's different the ANA the-- the human
error is really gone whether human cuz
like that an alligator is an actor you
know and you know depending on how you
draw like if you watch any of the old
busy roads you can see how like oh why
does blue looks so different a shock and
pay for the last well because someone
else drew it that's why Robert
Dangerfield looks so different yeah
what's the engine feel that someone
threw out the goddamn model should
happen to the movie like ah whatever and
this Cassini's or who's a frickin
schnauzer the same as a fat mess like
partway through hell raiser to when they
randomly change what the chatter looks
like road yeah oh there's also they do
actually and it's completely
inexplicable same with visual effects
you'll see those but like this five or
six visual effects studios on movie
you'll see like really great effects
number one shot you're like wow it looks
really fake yeah that's a girl that's
the B or C to B or D team yeah 10 let's
make that Alicia the d-team do it's
basically just the freaks and geeks of
the animation world yeah did it no we
had some laughs we had some tears
luggage would be a piano Terrell is mu P
days dead weight into all our fears
balls of frostbite falls oh yeah okay
elephants inflates I gotta say this
podcast time was very fun and great
mm-hmm man so so so till next time Frank
ass tubs frostbite balls and the
elephant show ladies awaits you these
the elephant flee to the elephant
inflates he do and as always boys and
girls also
just think thank you Mike for come on
show yeah thank you for doing our first
guest star oh my god this is what you
call a guest star shut up it's not my
tummy now our first our first I'm sorry
our first resident expert how much
expertise as a half did I actually a lot
you did voices and talked about a thing
all right exactly sink that's that we
could have had that without you that was
a moment that moment had food and beauty
and value I had this agreement this
episode of frankest have just brought to
you by a nondescript bear character not
a bear character whoo Oh else's fish Oh
again there well that's a no thank you
if you do that voice or boys maji if you
say certain words slower to self really
creepy pick a random word um just the
word Sheol truffle truffle truffle so
watch doesn't get systems like any
improv shows like I heard truffle first
tell me trouble
no that's the thing an L so you don't
want to hear like in a dark alley at
night variac wait no oh good it's late
at night oh that just tickles me so
tickles my first special thanks to Mike
for coming in thank you to Emmett for
being slight dog for our Foley for being
a G thang you to Erica for letting us
invade your workspace yeah I mean you
can speak up Thank You Garfield for
burgers on the block she's in booth but
she's not buddy perfect oh yeah
Nickerson hi oh this is a you haven't I
chose that was me that's one of my voice
of it oh no damn it Mike we're all Mike
this is all Mike's show I mean we're
just it's like phil hendrie where ya at
the delay yeah little known fact a Jerry
an error just characters at my place so
on behalf of air and i am j and on
behalf of mike as we're going down the
roster i'm aaron and i'm mike and as
always kids staying stage that stayed a
little bit stating folks this is a
dancer there's a theater upstairs that I
just sound like pop going yeah but it's
like I love it's like a better job Dylan
James game hey now if you do never
deliver put the an accent that be very
Ringo Oh buddy the ring that a good day
that is how we talk systems oh dude wait
wait close this out on a non stripped
bare character oh yes no I hope you
enjoyed i have a sort of die cast stones
to tune in next week where we hopefully
discuss our name and as always the
elephant and for its you frostbite Oh
Oh